what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu and this weekend
was disney's d23 expo and saturday was
marvel studios this panel where they got
to show us a lot of what is happening in
phase five sadly not much for phase six
just the official announcement that mack
shackman is going to indeed be directing
the fantastic four film but for phase 5
we actually did get a lot of exclusive
clips shown just to the people attending
d23 luckily for us though we do have
descriptions of what was shown and
although i wasn't there personally
people from the cosmic wonder team were
there to get all of the information and
descriptions that we needed so in this
video we'll be diving into detail about
the new black panther wakandan forever
trailer footage that was shown at d23
and breaking it down so let's break down
the new footage that was only shown to
the attendees of d23 where we'll see how
strong wakanda still is without their
king how strong neymar is and how doom
might actually be behind everything and
this footage actually did give us kind
of a more clearer picture of what
exactly is going on in wakanda forever
yes we know that it's essentially going
to be a battle between wakanda and
neymar and his people however it looks
like there is definitely more to it than
that the trailer starts off by queen
ramonda going to the united nations
assembly at the u.n being questioned by
multiple representatives including a new
character played by richard schiff queen
raimondo is being asked about vibranium
and how it can be used as a weapon for
mass destruction facing criticism for
its threat to global order the french
representative asked about how dangerous
it is to use vibraniums for weapons of
mass destruction since vibranium is
virtually undetectable by actual metal
detectors however queen raimonda assures
the assembly that wakanda has a policy
to never trade vibranium not under any
circumstances not because the element is
dangerous on its own but because of the
potential it holds in other people's
hands now as she says this the scene
cuts to another scene that takes place
in a wakandan research center we see a
group of people with guns infiltrate the
facility in search of vibranium tools
they find a vibranium covered wall and
markings and when they get to it and
activate it the markings light up
meanwhile it cuts back to the queen
saying at the un you perform civility
here but we know what you whisper in
your halls of leadership and in your
military facilities the king is dead the
black panther is gone they have lost
their protectors now while she's saying
this it keeps cutting back and forth
between that scene on the research
center but the dora milaje appears and
actually one of the dora malaji was
undercover disguised as a research
assistant it then shows the dora malaji
led by okoye going off against the
mercenaries who broke into the research
facility and as queen raimondo's talking
comes to an end we actually see the dora
milaje enter the assembly with the
mercenaries that they have defeated from
here the trailer showed old shots from
the first trailer it includes a glowing
sunset of wakanda and t'challa's funeral
and then we get more footage in this
time of namor it appears that queen
raimonda and namor are actually meeting
with each other however umbaku quickly
attacks neymar with the staff which
immediately smashes to pieces and when
embaku actually hits neymar namor
doesn't even react to the attack so for
those who were wondering if namor is
going to be big bad and strong the
answer is yes but the trailer ends with
an explosion on a city bridge and it
ends with a shot of the new black
panther and the final line that says
show them who we are and that was the
exclusive clip trailer that was shown at
d23 this past saturday now there are
some very important things to break down
here one is that you have to remember
what happened at the very end of the
first black panther film t'challa
addressed the united nations and said
that he was going to open wakanda's
resources to the rest of the world
everyone kind of laughed thinking that
wakanda was indeed a third world country
and had nothing to offer and it ended
with t'challa just kind of smiling
knowing that his country is actually the
richest in the world but now everybody
knows about wakanda and everybody knows
about vibranium and the world wants it
however wakanda refuses to trade it so
it seems like they are simply offering
their help to the rest of the world to
other countries but they are not
offering vibranium to other countries
and it's very clear why in this trailer
because queen raimonda and wakanda fear
that other countries will use it for
evil in this trailer clip queen ramonda
says that she doesn't fear vibranium but
what other people will do with it and
it's made very clear that other people
will try to use it for bad as the group
of soldiers attacks the research
facility but the dora melate are some of
the most skilled most fierce warriors on
the planet so they handled their own and
they even bring those soldiers who
attacked the research facility to the
united nations to prove a point and the
point is wakanda can handle their own
even though black panther and t'challa
are gone queen raimondo says i know what
you all whisper in your halls the king
is dead the black panther is gone they
have no protection so they did this for
a very specific point to show them that
wakanda is strong on its own yes they
lost their king and their leader but
they are still strong they still have
queen raimonda they still have the dora
milaje they still have umbaku and his
people and they also still have a black
panther who of course will be revealed
in this movie now one of the most
important things to focus on in this
clip was the fact that a wakandan
research facility was in fact invaded
this means that since wakanda will not
trade vibranium with the rest of the
world some of the world is trying to
take it by force and this very very well
could be other countries trying to take
it it seems very very clear that the
other countries of the un are very
concerned with the fact that wakanda has
vibranium and will not share it and they
state that they're concerned with people
making weapons of mass destruction when
the reality is they probably just want
it for themselves but it also makes you
wonder who else wants it and most of you
probably know who i'm thinking about
right now victor von doom aka dr doom
there have been rumors going around for
a while now that dr doom will be in
wakanda forever in some way shape or
form however i would like to point out
that this is not confirmed yet we do not
know for sure if he is going to be in
the film even though he is rumored to be
appearing in a post-credits scene we
know that rumors can be wrong look at
what happened at d23 however saying that
i do think it makes a lot of sense
especially if we follow the do-more
storyline from the comics this is very
important to know and i'll explain why
in the do more storyline doom helps the
disturbee gain access to wakanda they
actually dethrone t'challa and shuri and
completely take over wakanda and they
even put the x-men storm on trial
because she is t'challa's wife in the
comics at this point in time at least
and what's interesting is we learned
that doom actually infected all of
wakandans with food and water putting
nanites in them allowing him to use
these nanites and people basically as
cameras t'challa being the black panther
has heightened senses so he realized and
caught on to what was happening and
didn't partake of any food or water and
told shuri as well so she didn't and the
both of them managed to escape however
they quickly realized that doctor doom
was only helping the distillery so he
could get into wakanda and get vibranium
and the reason why is because dr doom
has discovered a secret that nobody else
has known it can amplify mystical
energies and its effects are infinite
and for somebody like doctor doom who is
already extremely strong with mystical
energies it can basically make dr doom
unstoppable this is why i think in
wakanda forever doctor doom could be
behind one of the groups at least trying
to break into wakanda to steal some
vibranium in fact he could even be
behind namor whether that's directly or
indirectly like i said in the comics
doom helps the destiry to gain access to
wakanda's vibranium he helps them
essentially take over wakanda the same
could be happening with neymar and the
atlanteans although they won't be
atlanteans in the film they're more
likely going to be an ancient aztec or
mayan race also another scene that was
shown during this clip at d23 was riri
williams aka ironheart conducting
projects on vibranium and from what we
know the projects are her making
machines that can actually detect
vibranium in the ocean now this could
clearly upset two people here one the
wakandans and two namor obviously
wakanda does not want vibranium getting
out to the public and obviously namor
does not want people going around his
parts of the ocean discovering his
people this is most likely how riri
williams actually ends up in wakanda but
this could actually be a part of doom's
plan send people into the ocean to look
for vibranium using the technology that
riri williams created to make namor mad
and go after wakanda then once wakanda
has been flooded because we've seen that
in the first trailer and basically
wakanda taken out doctor doom can then
go in and get vibranium now again this
is just a theory and right now the rumor
has it that it's only going to be a post
credit scene where doom shows up if that
is indeed true however with the
fantastic four coming to the mcu in 2025
and avengers secret wars coming to the
mcu that same year it doesn't make sense
to not have doctor doom in the mcu as he
is one of the main villains of the
fantastic four and he is pretty much the
main villain of secret wars we get god
emperor doom in that storyline but let
me know what you think about this in the
comments down below do you think doom
could be behind atlantis vs wakanda and
of course be sure to let me know what
you think about this new footage that
was shown at d23 in the comments down
below please don't forget to like the
video and subscribe to stay up to date
on the mcu and for live updates you can
always follow me on instagram and
twitter as always thank you all so much
for watching woof
you